a dawn raid in North London officers
suspect this property is being rented
out with illegal levels of overcrowding
but nothing could have prepared them for
this got a warrant thank these officers
you are 17 men crammed into a
three-bedroom house have you got an ID
please sir exploited by a landlord who's
pocketing three thousand pounds a month
in exchange for housing them in squalor
we've got young guys living for five to
a room paying extortionate amount of
rent to what we need to a landlord that
we don't actually know yet we found
serious disrepair lacking amenities no
heating 40 electrics some real serious
hazards it's a story that's being
repeated across the country caused by
high rents and a housing shortage of
crisis proportions so andreen has seen
the worst of it some point do you bath
from the guy upstairs the bath water was
leaking into above my stove work the
cooker and the whole cup area was full
of like mold and spores it was
disgusting she says one housing charity
described her home as the worst they had
ever seen and I just had to sleep in the
kitchen because there was no carpet
there and I ended up sleeping on chairs
for like three or four years and falling
over like every soft and and even then
the chairs the kitchen was still
infested with mice and we fleas but less
than that because of no carpet less than
the bedroom and I also had no toilet for
three years
how did you manage going to the toilet
what I had to go to Asda into the
library some a warning conditions in
private rental accommodation are so bad
they're reminiscent of the old slums as
captured by this photographer in the
1960s the private rental sector has
England's highest proportion of poor
housing with figures showing one-third
of privately rented homes are below the
government's decent home standard one in
six or seven hundred and forty thousand
her
are physically unsafe with severe
hazards including damp cold rodent
infestation and the risk of Falls and
injury rogue landlords are estimated to
be receiving 5.6 billion pounds a year
for renting out unsafe homes with rents
very high and the insecurity of the
private rented sector there's really
nowhere else to go there are options for
people so they are stuck where they are
and we need to build many more
affordable homes so that people do have
options and they can they do have other
places to live the private rental sector
is often portrayed as an attractive
lifestyle option but in reality more and
more low-income families and vulnerable
people are now being forced into it and
these houses may look perfectly normal
from the outside but inside conditions
are often quite the reverse the
government says its recent housing bill
will improve things with a new blacklist
and tougher powers to ban rogue
landlords but with people renting
properties like this because it's all
they can afford no one is offering a
solution as to where they will go our
four Hirsch Sky News